hello everyone and welcome to a most
exciting game that was played in a blitz
banter session between Magnus Carlsen
and Lauren's resume as you can see those
are their handles Maxie Boggs and the
Latin 56 I was played I already
mentioned on just 24 platform and it's a
really exciting game and it really
brings back memories if you remember if
you are if you are new to the chess
world or new to chess in general maybe
you don't remember but in 2014 they
played a famous match called too weak
too slow I also did a video on that game
so feel free to check that out I'll put
a link to it in the description below it
will be the first thing you see and also
if you want to see the original footage
of this game I will also put a second
link in the description below all impure
can recorded it for Twitter so you can
check that out as well but it's a really
exciting game cousin has the white
pieces and we have a really a crazy
King's Indian game so without further
ado let's check it out it's 5 years it's
time for a rematch let's see how it went
so Carson has the white pieces and for
some reason my board is flipped
I don't do videos with I would have
flipped the board sort of got that
across and has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 I like we mentioned we
have the Kings Indian Sultan Knight to
f6 we have c4 g6 Knight to c3 and
brush-up the g7 the King's Indian is on
the board cost and goes for efore we
have d6 this is the standard line of the
Kings Indian disruptor e to the Queen
and Bishop now guard the g4 square so
black castles already cross and is ready
to start the attack with the g4 frisson
a indeed castles and we do have g4 by
cost and so already starting the attack
and it's interesting I looked it up this
exact same position has been played many
times and black actually has a better
winning percentage than white in this
position black won some 46% of games and
one boy a white one
a 40% of games so I thought it was
interesting but this is just the King's
Indian a very very mysterious opening
but ok c5 with d5 grabbing more space in
the center and now there have been
plenty of moves but in this position a
success in place here he 5 has been
played here o'ciock has been played a
sixes been played but the more
frightening place has not been played
especially not in class
but this is a blitz game so why not be
five and it's not like a bank Oh be five
or something where you wanna break up
white center double the be pawns or
anything like that here Magnus can just
grab a clean phone not yet with Knight
captured because the night for a moment
guards the e4 pawn but Kozma just pushes
g5 he dislodges the Black Knight with
Knight back to b7 and now comes Knight
captures on b5 so Carlson grabs a clean
pawn and okay Bishop to a6 just now
threatening to capture and now miss up
White's pawn structure which would be
okay for black but cross and just
retreats with the night we have Knight
to c3 and now we have Knight to e5 and
already you can see that black is
getting some play for his sacrificed
pawn the knight and better part I'm that
c4 pawn already black is threatening to
win back the pawn and here Crossan has
to decide how to go about it best the
best idea is Queen b3 I just bring
another defender activating the Queen
but if you go something like b3 then
it's terrible for white then a friend I
had in mind Knight captures on c4
opening up the attack here he went back
the pawn and the white is not able to
recapture because of Bishop captures on
c3 with check you win the rook and it
will just be very good for black so
after 95 across and goes Knight back to
be 5 and now fresney captures it with
Bishop captures on d5 although there was
a another interesting line just Knight
captures on c4 so just grabbing material
and after Bishop captures you get Bishop
captures here Bishop captures and Queen
to a5 check now winning the bishop and
after Queen blocks Queen captures here
and the material would be equal but it's
just a very nice line for black really
controlling all of the dark squares here
tonight can be developed the rook can be
brought into the game you can push a 5 a
4 a very nice game plan for black but
it's a blitz game not to be over
analysed
so after Knight b5 Bishop captures we
have pawn captures and now c4
just playing very exciting chess as it
is a bliss game and he faces the world
champion so why not with f4 by Carson
and now just giving up yet another point
Knight to d3 check freshener seems to be
like like the honey badger he simply
doesn't care but shark after Sun d3c
capture Sun d3 Queen captures on d3 and
now Knight to d7 again black wants to go
to c5 this wood will come with an attack
on the Queen so he wants to save more
more time while developing his pieces we
have 90 to f3 crossing of course also
wants to develop pieces and not Knight
the c5 would an attack on the Queen also
pressuring the e4 pawn queen to e2
keeping an eye on the e4 pawn and now
comes Queen to a5 with check black
blocks and now comes Queen to a4 with
ideas of infiltrating with Queen to c2
but also there is the immediate threat
of just Queen captures on e4 as both the
the knight and Queen are attacking the
pawn so Crossin advances it we have E 5
and now you can choose a between some
lines you can go pawn captures or you
can go Knight to b3 also an interesting
line after Knight d1 still you would
have Knight capture screen captures and
now D captures on e5 f captures on e5
and Queen captures on a2 and with the
black King still being a white King
still being in the center and not really
have a lot of cover you don't really
gain anything by castling it would be we
even with White's massive pawns in the
center would be a pretty equal each game
but much easier to play for black so
after E 5 we've D captures on e5
pressing it again goes for the more
interesting line Knight captures on e5
and now comes the rush of captures on e5
here you cannot capture with the Queen
otherwise you get Queen in 93 check
winning the Queen so you have to capture
with the pawn we have pawn captures on
e5 and now comes look a to d8 just
pressuring the d5 pawn and here again
it's very dangerous to keep the King in
the center for example if you go
something like b4 attack the knight then
black can even go for this rook captures
on d5 pawn captures and now Queen here
attacking the a to pawn for da - da one
rook and also will clean up the center
here after rook to d1 you can just
capture here and even though white is up
a piece it will be very hard for whites
to play this with the King still being
the center
just you know a very dangerous position
especially in blitz where you don't have
a lot of time to figure out all the
squares your king can go to so here
crossing just castles and the now comes
rook captures on d5 we have b3 by Carson
attacking the Queen Queen to d4 check
now if you don't want to lose the bishop
you have to block with Bishop to e3 but
then you lose the five pawn Bishop to e3
and now paint captures on e5 so Carson
loses both D and the e pawn and now
black equalizes in material it's five
points each but blacks King is much
safer so black is to be preferred here
we have rook a to d1 by crossing rook
captures and d1 rook captures and d1 and
now just nice to e six going after the
g5 pawn and there's no good way of
really defending it if you got something
like this then you give up the control
of the g3 square just Queen g3 check now
you lose the h4 end sorry well not with
the Queen but obviously the night will
be able to capture so not something
Carlson wants to do after 96 we have a
for now Carlson is hoping that
everything just stays as it is he wants
to push a 5 b6 create a passed pawn on
the Queen side and try and push it all
the way Knight character son g5 by
Freston a and then out comes Queen to d3
and here presently starts the attack
against the white king Knight f3 check
and here a cross and goes King to f2
King to g2 was better because as you see
it doesn't allow the Knights to retreat
from h2 with check but here across and
plate came to f2 and now threaten a just
captured the night but now the problem
is the knight has a retreat square while
delivering check and now this is much
better for black Bishop captures on a7
cross and now clears the way for his
past pawns to be queen but there's a
problem
Knight to g4 check now the Queen has
clear path here to the h2 square if king
of three then Queen h5 is very strong
the knight doesn't allow the king to
retreat to a dark square and of course
if you go back then we get to the same
line as has happened in the game and if
you go up the board then well you can
even lose the Queen so well not
immediately as the best of courage the
f2 square but just Queen a5 and your
King will be in huge trouble
so after this King to g2 move for sna
won't we
- H - check we've killer king - f1 now
still the bishop covers the F 2 square
so no immediate checkmate is possible
and here F resonate just repeats
moonwalk moves a couple of times Queen
to f4 check King to e2 with Queen - H to
check with King - f1 Queen to f4 check
and here Carlson goes kinky 1 and now
fresh and I finally sees that the Queen
and Knight are not able to finish the
job on their own he introduces the rook
into the attack we have looked a c8 now
and for a moment the Queen is guarding
the c2 square but only for the moment we
have Bishop to g1 by Carson and
interestingly this Bishop the g1 will
allow a beautiful combination that well
will happen very shortly so do pay
attention with Queen to e5 width check
cross and retreats King to f1 now comes
Queen back to a4 with check King to g2
and now comes Knight to e5 attacking the
Queen hoping to free the c2 square for
the black rook the cousin goes Queen to
e2 still keeping an eye on the rook and
now comes the line that became possible
when Carson put - this bishop on b1 so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for black here as
Carson is about to get checkmated I'll
give you a couple of seconds you know
just just figure it out it's a blue this
game so you know feel free to enjoy it
while you're calculating for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are definitely not
too weak or too slow and for those who
just wanna enjoy show the of course Rock
the c2 s Carson did try to keep the rook
away from the c2 square simply won't
work and now you see that this is
possible due to the special being on g1
as the King will not be able to retreat
the G 1 square the only move is either
to lose the Queen or you can block lose
the rook and then lose the Queen so
cross and just grab the rook there is no
better move and now comes Queen to f3
check and now you can see the king is
unable to go to g1 the King has to go to
h2 and now
well it's mating one of course everyone
if you can see it nice - g4 checkmate
the Queen covers all these squares and
the King is unable to retreat here so
it's of course chairman
but yeah just a wonderful game and an
excellent rematch by Lauren Preston a
who finally you know they takes back
well maybe in another few years we'll
have another interesting game now
between the two of them another one that
we can call too weak too slow and it
will again be a very interesting game
such as this one alright but yeah that's
just the Kings Indian first he gave the
b5 pawn then he pushed C for a 93 check
gave up that pawn as well and it just
all works out that's why you should play
the Kings Indian and that's why you know
it's always very exciting to play
positions that are well that are not
proportional or just very exciting so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Corner Stinson
anastacio McKesson are both games a Roth
min and the max trainer for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous video see
her thank all for watching and I will
see you soon most likely even today
we're continuing the Capablanca saga as
we've said so III do hope you'll enjoy
that as well thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day